the wings are for you sir with the
homemade help very barbecue so thank you
for the wings French
I believe they come frozen Gena news
coming boatman huh yeah you can't buy
fresh chicken locally here being served
frozen food wasn't the start I was
looking for it looks like it's been
dipped in LT blood in fact the food just
kept getting worse pulling back that
ribeye is like pulling back that duvet
on a mattress that's stained and wow
that's strong and alcohol he's a good
wine for this right I hope Gena claims
our hands are tied in the kitchen so at
this point I don't know who to blame
rice is mustard you could then what
Idaho rainbow trout with the herb
risotto Jesus what's all the squidgy
bits around the outside those are other
sauces all the sauces yeah is that
risotto or some of the plaster that your
dad left over and building the new lodge
they still got the scales on it as well
why would you leave the skin that soggy
like some used condom that has to be the
worst trout I've ever seen in my entire
career Wow does mom and dad see this
food do they come and have dinner and he
hate everything
they hate the deer sure everything they
don't like the way that she does
anything why is she here
when you're in the heat of the season we
kind of just take what we can get you
can't keep on changing your chef every
year I agree we do it every year okay
now if this place wasn't run by your
parents did you work here
hell no no not for a second I don't want
to run a restaurant how keaneally to get
out I'm desperate I mean if you got a
job tomorrow would you be awful yeah I
feel like I've kind of done my part the
part that I told them that I would do
you oversee concerned and you're doing
more out
affection as opposed to you really want
to be here sounds like your mind's made
up
[Music]
Wow let's get them out please would you
both come out please
all those come out yeah what if I don't
want to Chef Ramsay nice to meet you
likewise good to see you too Wow so I'm
not so words what feedback did you get
throughout my lunch I didn't say
anything
nothing yeah course by course you didn't
even talk to them no why not I figured
that was what you're gonna do when we
were done it's hopefully at least you're
gonna say something to them so they can
up their game no I actually expected you
to say something and I thought well
should I ask her I kept thinking okay
must be ok I have heard any comments
don't you want the truth oh absolutely
how'd you know the owners hate your
dishes no you don't know the owners hate
your food no I did not know that you've
got no idea that Dede can't stand the
curry no I never knew that I feel like
people have been lying to me do you know
I don't blame her let me I'm gonna be
frank
everybody was overcooked it look like
we'd opened at the bottom the dishwasher
and that plug was blocked with bits of
floating grease you may find it funny
but you know I was funny the way this
girl no I'm not trying to laugh by the
room no no you know look we sat though
if you phoned me on my telephone in the
car and asked me what do you think I'm
gonna be having I would have never
mentioned those dishes